on Sunday whilst the city was being
turned into a swamp I'm it up with rod
who runs a radio show called fuzzy logic
and Tom who studies nuclear fusion we
had a chat over coffee to decide what we
wanted to talk about on air and once we
got to the studio I asked rod to show me
how things work behind the scenes the
the operation of the console is fairly
basic you have all these inputs so I
play a CD and and then I press that
button and there's nothing in so I can
cue it up other check mark and guest
microphones and my microphone those
buttons there turn the lights on and
we're just talking over the top of live
radio I've got a little stale and
basically you're just struggling
normally input supplying them as as you
need to understand of science know what
to ask news next and all this and that's
right that's why I say it's like driving
a car when you when you start driving a
car you know you're all the time you
think you can clutch steering wheel
what's this lever doing and then there's
the car over there the purse is talking
to you the radio is going a lot of
information coming in and you're
synthesizing you're digesting all that
well I hope you haven't had any crashes
bicycle first let's have a look at
plants now October what is a physicist
doing researching planets exactly so I
am a physicist and it's funny because
before I worked on plants I was actually
doing astronomy research but there are
some fundamental questions in the nature
of plant science and biophysics that a
physicists can actually contribute to
I'm looking at how plants protect
themself from diseases so plant diseases
are caused by something called a
pathogen a pathogen is an organism that
lectures on to a plant cell
and then starts to tunnel through the
cell wall and wreak havoc and cause
disease and I'm thinking like a castle
wall you know you've got the invaders
outside you've got the people on the
inside
tipping buckets of all of them they're
Manning the buttresses and they're
fending them off and while the invaders
are trying to get inside now
what does a plant do you've got you've
got these bugs there's all pathogens as
you call them the castle is actually a
good analogy for the cell wall so plant
cells have this very rigid structure
around the outside and that is to act as
a gatekeeper really to keep out bad
things from the cell things like a
pathogen and to let through good things
like nutrients and water and to allow
the life to continue within the cell so
when a pathogen is trying to attack a
plant cell the cell wall or the castle
actually has a few defenses to keep it
out and to keep the cells safe
[Music]